[Music]
[Music]
it is seven o'clock which means you're
watching the only breakfast show
live from westminster boris johnson uh
well he admits there are many things he
wishes he'd done differently during the
pandemic
and he probably feels the same after
apparently telling his back ventures the
uk's
vaccine success was down to capitalism
and greed meanwhile the home secretary
is planning to overhaul the asylum
system
we'll be asking her about that on the
programme shortly uh but also this
morning
just a half for me we'll be speaking to
the landlady who was
so bored during lockdown that she
created a miniature version of her own
tavern
join us in her pint-sized pub at 10 to
9.
but also this morning the pen is
mightier than the
tablets we will speak to the lover of
letters we've got ourselves
88 pandemic pen pals from all around the
world that's coming your way
on this wednesday the 24th of march
held to account boris johnson faces a
tough end of term interrogation on covet
19
by senior mps
a jab that could needle europe the pm
backtracks after joking that the uk's
vaccine success is
down to capitalism and greed
targeting the people smugglers the home
secretary is due to overhaul the asylum
system
critics say the changes are divisive and
ineffective
more protests in bristol 14 people
arrested after another
killed the build demonstration in the
city
hoping to make an impact prince harry
lands a job at a u.s
coaching and mental health firm we've
been hearing from his new boss
we were just so impressed and really um
i think there was such a natural
chemistry and synergy
one person dies in flooding on the east
coast of australia
as officials warned that water levels
will continue to rise
and it's turning increasingly unsettled
for this week
with cooler conditions and the risk of
some wintry showers
for some spots of the north i'll have
all the details later in the programme
morning all boris johnson is likely to
face some tough questioning
about his handling of the coveted
pandemic by senior mps
after claiming the uk is making progress
a year since the first lockdown
as candles were lit across the country
to remember victims of the virus
the pm told a private meeting of back
benchers that the uk's vaccine success
was down to capitalism and greed before
later backtracking
the remarks were not believed to have
been made in connection with the current
route with the european union over
supplies
our chief political correspondent john
craig has our first report
from the steps of 10 downing street to
iconic
blackpool tower and the bell tower of
bradford city hall
and from the market town of caldecott in
monmouthshire
to the village of dorman's land in
surrey
the nation rounded off the anniversary
of the first lockdown
with light shows and candles for those
who died in the past year
[Applause]
those attending this vigil included a
woman who lost her husband to cancer
during the pandemic i know a handful of
people who are in our situation
so they've either lost someone or
they're preparing for loss
so tonight wasn't just about my family
but everyone in this village and you
know globally that have lost someone
after observing a minute's silence boris
johnson
who almost died from covid last year
spoke of his own emotions i certainly
think that this is something that we
will all remember and
be dealing with in different ways for
probably for certainly in my case for as
long as uh
as i live it's been an extraordinary uh
moment in our in our in our history in a
deeply
difficult and distressing period
today in the commons as well as the last
prime minister's questions for three
weeks
mr johnson faces a potentially tough
interrogation on kovid by the liaison
committee
made up of senior mps who chair all
party select committees
labour says mr johnson must be held to
account
over his handling of the pandemic it's
right that we ask questions
as to why our death rate is so high one
of the highest
in the world it's right that we ask
ourselves if we could have done things
differently
if we could have locked down sooner if
we'd have invested in our nhs
and our public health and social care
provision whether
we would have been less vulnerable and
less exposed to this
virus the pm says that a year after
lockdown
the country is making progress step by
step
but there are warnings that another wave
of infections
is inevitable john craig sky news
welcome back to the program the home
secretary pretty patel miss patel great
to have you on the show again i do hope
you're well
um lots of lots of course to talk about
in terms of the changes uh
to immigration and asylum but i wonder
if we can start though with
with covid19 and the vaccines those
comments that the prime minister made at
conservatives mp
mps last night when he said that the
uk's vaccine success was
was due to capitalism and greed what did
he mean
well look i actually wasn't in the
meeting so i didn't hear those remarks
but i think first of all
prime minister always acknowledges the
strong success that we've had in terms
of the vaccine not just the
rollout which is incredible but also our
ability as a country to
develop the vaccine um the role that
pharmaceutical companies and science and
technology
has played in that and actually i think
that speaks to a great strength that we
have
as a country and linked to that of
course look at our contributions to
kovacs the international scheme to get
vaccine supplies elsewhere
and demonstrate that we are very very
strong force for good
internationally when it comes to vaccine
science
and pharmaceutical development well i
understood of course that
you weren't in the meeting but it does
appear that the the prime minister
stopped channeling his inner gordon
gecko and backtracked perhaps because of
the fact
that as things stand reports this
morning that the european union is about
to
announce the measures that they can put
in place to slow the transit of vaccines
from the continent to the united kingdom
i wonder what you make of that and
whether or not you see that perhaps as a
a success down to capitalism and greed
well i think first of all when it comes
to the european union
discussions are always ongoing in terms
of the vaccine and supplies of the
vaccine
and it's important it's absolutely
imperative that we all work together
in a collective way and a responsible
way because this is about saving lives
this is exactly what the vaccine is
doing
yesterday we marked the annual the year
anniversary
of lockdown but also took great
reflection as a nation in terms of the
lives that have been lost and also how
far we have come
over the last 12 months so i don't think
this is about you know
really just just sort of criticizing
vaccine supplies we've got to work
together support each other
and just ensure as we've got taking
place anyway across government
that dialogue continues discussions are
constantly underway and that's right and
proper
um well let's move straight on to your
brief uh shall we home secretary and
and some fairly significant changes that
you're making today to immigration
policy the detail of which has already
been quite
quite well reported so i wonder if you
might er
just exactly just establish exactly what
what the point of all this is what is
the
end goal of the changes that you're
making to the immigration system
so today i am effectively announcing a
new plan for immigration
and this builds upon the work that we've
already done with regards to immigration
so
we've ended free movement we've
developed a point based system
but that's the legal side of immigration
and migration
we have a fundamental problem actually
in the world when it comes to illegal
migration
and lives are being lost too frequently
with people
trying to basically travel flee
but also come to the united kingdom in
the hands of people smugglers
so today i am announcing changes um
which will be subject to consultation
and i'll be announcing this in
parliament later on today
there'll be a command paper where we're
looking at a range of options as to how
we can reform
the entire asylum system and importantly
for people that are fleeing persecution
um from terrible parts of the world we
know for a fact there are something like
80 million people that are displaced in
the world
we want to create safe and legal routes
for them
in terms of how they can be protected
and also
be received in our asylum system in the
right way
as asylum seekers and be supported in
their resettlement in the united kingdom
tell us then just a little bit more home
secretary what are these
legitimate routes to claiming asylum
here in the united kingdom as things
stand isn't it the case that
you have to be in the united kingdom to
make an application for asylum
well that's the point we are looking to
create safe and legal routes
to support people that are feeling
persecution currently we have
records number of people even yesterday
we had 150 people
um in the hands of smugglers come over
to the united kingdom
no one denies there is an issue with
people coming across the channel i'm
just wondering what these new legitimate
routes
to claiming asylum will be well we're
publishing a paper today where we're
discussing and putting out consultation
how we will develop new safe and legal
routes working as we've done
as we do already as a government with
the likes of unhcr
refugee agencies to support people
who are fleeing but in country so in
country and how we can develop those
routes because this is really important
by developing safe and legal routes we
stop people from being put in the hands
of smugglers
and people traffickers too many people
have died trying to come to the united
kingdom
we've got to break this people smuggling
model we've got to put in safe and legal
rules
and we've actually got to be able to
help genuine asylum seekers
not just flee persecution but be
resettled in the united kingdom
currently our arm system is overwhelmed
we have a number of areas that we are
announcing today where we're looking at
where is that where is the evidence
though um home secretary what is the
evidence that they change these changes
where is the evidence that these changes
will will convince people not to take
these routes i mean if you're fleeing
genocide if you're fleeing rape gangs if
you're fleeing
war your priority is survival it strikes
me that the first thing that people will
want to do is get away
rather than necessarily pop down to the
british embassy well actually that's
exactly why
we will create safe and legal routes
working with the right kind of partners
and to be to be frankly we've done this
already if you look at the syrian
resettlement scheme 25 000 people have
been resettled in the united kingdom
through a safe and legal route and this
is effectively
what we want to create much more of to
help people
currently the people that are coming
over to the united kingdom are prom
predominantly individual men leaving
behind women and children that are
fleeing persecution that desperately
need help
and we need to change our asylum system
from an end-to-end perspective so there
are lots of structures that we need to
change within the system itself we need
to change our approach not just to case
working
but the way in which we can help people
yes get to the united kingdom and be
resettled in the united kingdom
and currently we simply do not have an
effective system that is doing that
because our system is being gained by
people smugglers and facilitators and
this is what we're seeing on a
day-to-day basis
nearly 60 percent of what we have in our
asylum system right now
people there have come to the united
kingdom through illegal routes
putting their own you've made you've
made we've made that point
we've made that point home secretary i
just want to know what happens though
the biggest problem appears to be people
on the other side of the channel
coming to the united kingdom and
claiming asylum under the new system
that you're proposing
if people cross the channel illegally
claim asylum and have that asylum claim
fail what happens to them well part of
our plan and our approach will be around
how we
remove people and return people to their
countries that they have traveled from
so we have to remember that there's any
arrangements in place with with the
european union
well we will have rearrangements in
place and that is what we're doing right
now in terms of bilateral negotiations
to put arrangements in place
and it's important to remember if you're
fleeing persecution people can claim
asylum in the first safe country so
france germany
italy belgium spain many people are
traveling to the united kingdom from
these safe countries
so the principle of fleeing fleeing
persecution under the refugee convention
and seeking asylum is very much about
yes going to a safe country and people
are still shopping through
safe countries and coming to the united
kingdom but but all of this rests on
those those bilateral agreements doesn't
it if germany says no if france says no
if any of those countries
say no then we all in this essence have
a situation which people are you know
indefinitely detained in the united
kingdom
well it's not just about european union
countries and i think it's important
you've already heard me say this
it's quite it's quite a lot about
european countries though isn't it
who are displaced around the world right
now eu countries also have a moral duty
and a responsibility to be part of this
solution
and today i'll be at the g6 talking
about this very issue
and making the case for reform of asylum
and absolutely sticking to the principle
of claiming asylum in the first safe
country because currently that is not
taking place
we all have a moral duty and
responsibility to save lives
and stop people smuggling and this is a
collective endeavor where we must all
step out
are we uh is part of the proposal that
that's been put out to consultation the
idea that places like gibraltar the isle
of man
could be used uh can you reject that
speculation it certainly was rejected
uh rejected by the authorities in
gibraltar
well first of all all the time people
are being trafficked and smuggled
through illegal routes
we as a government have a duty and a
responsibility to consider all options
and that is the purpose of our
conservation so we are we will look at
third country removal
and we will also do that alongside
looking at bilateral agreements so
this will be work that this government
is undertaking right now
and as part of this consultation we will
put all options on the table
in terms of working with their countries
and countries like denmark are already
exploring options like this
and we will continue to explore
bilaterally options in terms of
returning and removing people that have
come to the united kingdom illegally
um home secretary i wonder if we can
just touch on on policing at the tail
end of our conversation this morning and
and of course the police bill uh going
through the commons at the moment um
that which we saw in bristol at the
weekend
what could the police have done in
bristol at the weekend
under the proposed legislation that they
can't currently do
well first of all in terms of the
changes
and obviously this is subject to
parliamentary procedure in the commons
and committee stages
with the bill itself this is very much
about changes to static process
um protests so as we know the
public public order act needs updating
it was put in place in the 1980s
but we're seeing new tactics being used
by static protesters
so we've seen individuals such as and
organizations like
exile glue themselves to buildings cause
a great deal of public disruption
stop ambulances from getting out to
emergency calls
and the powers like the events like the
one we saw in bristol the weekend
could be policed in the way under the
legislation that we currently have
though
absolutely not and this is the point the
police do not have the powers to remove
individuals
that are causing a disruption and also
threat to life we saw
last year and the year before last as
well through the protests that took
place threats to life
i saw it myself with dangerous dangerous
situations with
particular protesters rigging themselves
up to vehicles into fuel tanks
and putting the lives of other people at
risk alongside stopping
just a bog stand of public defense
sorry neil so sorry for interrupting
because we're just running up i'm just
wondering the stuff that you're
describing why is that just not just a
bog standard public order offence
because these are new tactics that
protesters are using and they're
dangerous tactics
so these are tactics that we have to
consider as part of the bill
we're working with the police on this as
well and we work with the police every
time there are protests where there are
issues that we can learn from and there
are currently gaps in the legislation as
i said the legislation itself is
outdated it's from the 1980s
pretty patel great to have you on the
show this morning thanks for being with
us
uh sky's joe pike was lurking in the
wings listening to that chat with
the home secret morning joe um some
significant changes coming down the
pipeline in terms of immigration
yeah and those in the home office and
pretty patel touched on this are very
clear this is really about
boats traveling from france people
traveling from france in different ways
and trying to get rid of the pull factor
it was interesting her talking about the
lives lost in the hands
of people smugglers but we still don't
really know
how these people who whose applications
are rejected will be deported
and now we've left the eu now the dublin
arrangements have sort of
got rid of whereby we have arrangements
the eu countries
to deport people to the country they
first arrived in the eu from we were in
a quite difficult situation i also
thought secondly
very interesting on the eu and vaccines
we know that
on thursday e-leaders will decide what
to do around
perhaps tightening uh their rules on
exports of vaccine vaccine products from
the eu to other countries
pretty patel trying to sort of dial down
the rhetoric i think talking
about working together about dialogue
continuing
we need to work collectively and
responsibly maybe slightly different
tone from
the private comments boris johnson made
to 1922 talking about
greed and it does seem from reports
overnight the eu will
toughen up their regulations and that
clearly could be a very difficult have a
significant impact
on the rollout in the uk vaccinations
certainly good job
thanks very much uh plenty still to come
on the program this morning including
this i'll be speaking to the
shadow business business minister lucy
powell on why she believes the
government
needs to do more to back british steel
uh shortly after half past seven
after a new report suggests that nhs
staff in england have suffered a real
terms
pay cut over the last decade we'll be
chatting to the royal college of nursing
uh
nursing director at far past eight
and just how likely is that summer
holiday abroad at half-past eight
we'll be speaking to the travel
presenter and author simon reeve
about the possibility of venturing
overseas in the coming months
now let's turn to california now where
prince harry
has taken on a job the duke is starting
at a coaching and mental health business
better up as their chief impact officer
our u.s correspondent greg milam has
been speaking to the company's chief
executive
this is the latest stop on prince
harry's journey out of the realm of
working royal
and if the offices of his new employer
remain shuttered
due to the pandemic the real world
concerns of life in san francisco
very much on the doorstep but prince
harry now appears on the website of
better up
as its new chief impact officer welcome
to growth and
transformation with betterup where every
employee builds the skills
mindsets and behaviors needed to perform
at their peak
he was actually a client himself in
contact with one of the personal coaches
they say
can make employees feel more positive
engaged and connected
the app's founder explained what a
prince can bring
we were just so impressed and really um
i think there was such a natural
chemistry and synergy around
the insights and the contributions he
can make creativity
to better up in ensuring that we achieve
our mission so what is a chief impact
officer
bigger than commercial success this is
about global impact and so as we
crafted the role together again those
four buckets of opportunities
we came to the title of chief impact
officer really denoting that he's
focused on our mission and he's focused
on ensuring that we're doing everything
we can
to achieve our mission on a bigger and
larger and grander scale to impact the
lives of more people they haven't
disclosed how much the duke will earn or
what the terms of his contract will be
but then
as he's a private citizen now why would
they they have said
this isn't just a celebrity joining the
board of directors he's coming as an
executive who will
work attending meetings and company
events
he has said he wants to help have an
impact on people's lives
whatever when the duke does come here
for meetings he'll be a warm welcome
we're open open you know to everybody
kind of coming coming to the city and
you know kind of you know having having
their hand and and making it uh
making it better if that happens he's
sensational
we're lucky to have him that's how i
feel i think that's how a lot of us feel
i read that this morning hearing that he
um
was going to with mental health right so
hearing that is also really great
um considering his wife's situation
um i think that's a really great step
forward for many americans that
interview not only generated headlines
it introduced them to the sussex brand
and brought a hefty amount of sympathy
and support a new job
another sign they are well and truly now
a fixture of american life greg milam
sky news san francisco
uh well let's take a look at some of the
other stories making the news this
morning
and president biden has called for a ban
on assault weapons and high-capacity
magazines
following a mass shooting in colorado on
tuesday
police have charged a 21-year-old man
with 10 counts of murder
last week another 21 year old was
charged with shooting
eight people dead at massage parlors in
georgia joe biden urged congress
to swiftly pass gun control laws
i don't need to wait another minute let
alone an hour
to take common sense steps that will
save the lives
in the future and to urge my colleagues
in the house and senate to act
we can ban assault weapons and
high-capacity magazines
in this country once again this is not
it should not be a partisan issue this
is an american issue
it will save lives american lives
and we have to act
[Applause]
14 people have been arrested in bristol
following a protest against a new bill
which gives the police new powers to
tackle demonstrations
specialist officers were called to move
around 130 people who gathered in
college green
all this three days after another
violent protest in the city
left 21 police officers injured
a large shipping container has blocked
egypt's suez canal
causing a traffic jam of ships around 15
are said to be stuck behind the ship
called
evergreen pictured here with several
tugboats being deployed to help move the
400 meter long vessel at the suez canal
of course one of the world's busiest
waterways
with about 12 percent of the world's
trade passing through it
a woman has been killed in sydney after
floodwater tractor in her car
she is the first fatality of the
australian east coast floods
with the prime minister scott morrison
calling it a terribly sad day
parts of new south wales have been hit
by the worst floods seen there in more
than 50 years
and while the rain has eased authorities
are warning that the river levels are
continuing to rise david richardson
reports now from sydney
back inside their flood devastated home
for the first time
it's a heartbreaking moment for this
young couple this
is their first home that's the hardest
part like
it's not even it's not even like the
money
it's like the beautiful gardens that
we've made and
all the effort we've made to fix up the
backyard
and it's just wiped away in a day yeah
blake and mel moved here 18 months ago
when they left last night they thought
the worst
was over they were wrong the damage is
worse than they ever imagined
a lot of cleanup and then we'll figure
out whether we want to live here for
much longer or what we do so yeah it's
definitely
made us question the choice to live here
the sun might now be shining for the
first time in 10 days
but the unthinkable has happened the
water levels
have risen yet again british landscaper
paul luckman's house is now under real
threat
like every flood damaged house in this
street he's not covered by insurance
it would cost up to twenty thousand
pounds a year
to ensure against flood and these people
just can't afford it it's heartbreaking
yeah well it is when you you know you
work all year and you put a few pennies
away and how you spend it fix your house
scenes like this are being repeated
right across new south wales today
as people return to their homes for the
first time to survey the damage
they all believed the same thing that
the worst
was finally over they now all know the
same thing
the horrible reality
another horrible reality communities
isolated by flood waters
low on crucial supplies hundreds of tons
of staples and fresh water
loaded onto a flotilla of emergency
boats
and transported to villages literally
without a thing
while several hundred people have safely
fled their homes
many have remained behind all over this
area
to continue fighting the rising water to
save
what they can they don't want to be like
so many others
losing everything all anyone can do now
is wait and pray these waters will
subside
then the cleanup can begin david
richardson
sky news australia
just a reminder that sky news is
launching the first daily prime time
news program dedicated to climate change
you can watch the daily climate show
that's every weekday
at half past six in the evening from
wednesday the 7th of april
uh let's take a look at a couple of the
other stories i'm making the news today
uh the foreign secretary has called for
nato to take a stand against the threat
posed by russia
ahead of a meeting with other foreign
ministers in brussels later today
dominic rabb will urge nato allies to
ensure that moscow faces
consequences for destabilizing actions
including
cyber attacks and spreading
disinformation about coronavirus
north korea fired two cruise missiles
off its west coast on sunday according
to south korea and the united states
this just days after kim jong-un's
sister threatened both countries for
holding
joint military exercises president biden
says the missile launches
were not a provocation
a new saliva test has been found to
accurately detect concussion
in professional rugby players the scrum
study led by academics at the university
of birmingham
developed a non-invasive test which can
predict the result of a head injury
assessment
with 94 accuracy researchers hope to
turn it into a pitch site
test that can provide an accurate
reading shortly after the concussion has
taken place
the hollywood actor george seagal has
died at the age of 87.
the oscar nominee who played albert pop
solomon in the american sitcom the
goldbergs
and starred in who's afraid of virginia
woolf passed away after
complications from bypass surgery his
co-stars are among those who pay tribute
online
ah well let's see how the weather is
looking this wednesday it's a beautiful
morning here
in westminster tell us what's the rest
of the country looking like
not too bad there will be some good
spells of sunshine at times but there is
also some cloud and patchy rain moving
its way south eastwards over
england and wales and the north and west
will see some pretty heavy showers
becoming widespread this afternoon
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies the
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning well there's lots of bits
and bobs going on with the weather for
today and in fact for the rest of the
week we are going to continue with the
unsettled theme in fact becoming
more unsettled than it has been recently
and cooler with the risk of some wintry
showers
in fact for this morning there may be a
few wintry showers across the high
ground
of northwest scotland otherwise it's
rain showers there and the same for
ireland and northern ireland
but most of these areas across island
northern ireland scotland
will be mainly dry and sunny the same
two across the north and west of
england and wales further south and east
of england and wales there's lots of
clouds
mr merc across the eastern areas patchy
light rain and drizzle also moving its
way south and eastward so for much of
the day
the south and east will be quite cloudy
for this afternoon the rest of england
wales becoming brighter widespread heavy
showers though for island northern
ireland and scotland some heavy
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
nice thank you still to come on
breakfast this morning we'll be talking
to a human rights barrister about the
government's plans to overhaul the uk's
immigration system that's coming soon
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know
they say they can't go back to myanmar
yet if they do
they fear they'll be killed
[Applause]
[Music]
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
if there is a bigger explosion this area
would be
in the danger zone
[Music]
these traffic jams snake for hours up
and down this hillside it means pressure
day
can't access those and knees
[Music]
you can see the depth of water if you
have a look in front of us
there are people wading through it
[Music]
i think experiencing the two million
person march in hong kong
that was a moment i don't like the
chinese government it's true
[Music]
it was real people power in action
police have been firing tear gas and
rubber balloons
see fires all around us here and just
one of them is the size of around 31 000
football pitches siobhan robbins sky
news
bangkok
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the government is setting
out what it calls
the biggest overhaul in decades to the
uk's immigration system today
the home secretary says it will tackle
the people smugglers
who endanger life by facilitating
illegal entry to the uk
and just a little earlier on the program
pretty patel told us
it was the responsibility of all
european countries to tackle the problem
well it's not just about european union
countries and i think it's important
you've already heard me say neil
80 million people who are displaced
around the world right now
eu countries also have a moral duty and
a responsibility
to be part of this solution and today
i'll be at the g6
talking about this very issue and making
the case for
reform of asylum and absolutely sticking
to the principle of claiming asylum in
the first safe country because currently
that is not taking place
we all have a moral duty and
responsibility to save lives
and stop people smuggling and this is a
collective endeavor where we must all
step up
uh joining us now sangeeta ayangar a
human rights banister
at goldsmith's chambers uh sangeeta
great to see you this morning um
on the basis of that which we have heard
from the home secretary what has been
published in the pakista admittedly
fairly significant overhaul of the
immigration system
well neil as a barrister i'm concerned
by the catalogue of legal errors that
underpin this proposal what's being
suggested is that asylum seekers should
be judged for international protection
not based on need but on their mode of
transport
to the uk which shows either a total
misunderstanding of the law or is
seeking to misrepresent the uk's legal
obligations
so taking just three of the suggestions
that
um the home secretary suggested this
morning and looking at them
dispassionately through the lens of the
law and firm
facts and figures this notion of
so-called
illegal immigration which is really the
central kernel of that justifies the
entire plan
simply doesn't exist in law it is simply
not correct
it's a dangerous lie all routes to enter
the uk
to claim asylum are lawful and
legitimate
and there is nothing that allows
countries like the uk
a signatory to the refugee convention to
criminalize arrivals by boat
or to disqualify an asylum claim on that
basis
the opposite is true we have a legal
obligation
to fully fairly and properly assess
all claims based on need for asylum
and it's concerning that the home office
would repeatedly abuse this term
illegal a dangerous lie to spin and
propagate
especially from the corridors of power
it is though
a phrase that which home secretaries
have repeated over the years that you
can claim asylum in the first safe
country that you come to there are
concerns shared by the by the home
sector itself this morning about about
the system being overwhelmed
uh by applicants for asylum i mean
taking those two points together
do you at least understand why the the
home secretary feels that there is
a need to try and do something if other
european countries are unwilling to take
these individuals then
why should the united kingdom seems to
go the logic
well again this idea of safe countries
an asylum seeker who moves on
is not breaking the law by doing so and
it doesn't disqualify them from refugee
status
it's long been recognized that there are
many lawful
logical and legitimate reasons why an
asylum seeker
would seek to come to the uk and it's
not the responsibility of a home
secretary
to pre-judge and to limit and
pre-determine
asylum claims but looking at actually
what the
what the state of affairs is asylum
claims are at a historic
low number of people who claimed asylum
last year was
half the annual number in 2002
so if the numbers are low why are we
changing the entire system
what's actually skyrocketed is the time
that asylum seekers have to wait
for a decision from the home office so
over 50
000 people have had to wait for over six
months
for a decision on their asylum claim
there's nothing in the asylum process
slowing that down
that's purely the home office causing
delay
what's proposed in this new plan is
nothing that will actually improve
the efficiency of the asylum process
it's unworkable and unlawful and it's
attempting to
undo the refugee convention which on
this
2021 is the 70th anniversary of the uk
becoming a signatory to it's it's
appalling really
sangeeta ayanggar great to have you on
the show this morning afraid we have to
leave it there but thanks for being with
us
thank you now labour
is calling for the government to back
british steel
by guaranteeing it will be used in all
government infrastructure projects
it comes after analysis by the party
found that 24 p
in every pound spent on steel for such
projects did in fact go abroad
the shadow minister of business and
consumers lucy powell joins us once
again on the program ms paul great to
have you on
um just just explain the problem as you
as you see it
with the way in which big infrastructure
projects big public
infrastructure projects are not
necessarily relying on british steel as
much as they could
well it is it is a big problem because
uk
domestic steel production is vital
not just for the thousands of jobs that
it supports important well-paid
decent jobs but because we need
that for our own security and our own
resilience and for our economy sort of
relies on it's a foundational uh
industry
in in that sense and over the last few
years as we're seeing
at the moment with with liberty steel as
well uk steel really has
uh had lots of ups and downs really and
and it needs that long-term security of
knowing
that these big infrastructure projects
like hs2
like nuclear power like offshore wind
and so on
which is the british government paying
those contracts that it will have
a long-term future with that with those
contracts coming
to uk steel so we're calling on the
government to
have a buy british guarantee
underpinning
the contracts for these big
infrastructure projects and we think
that will
bring around 4.4 billion pounds to the
uk economy
and protect and create around 50 000
jobs over the next few years
is isn't this just subsidizing the
british steel industry by by a different
name i mean presumably part of the
reason that big infrastructure projects
go overseas
to buy steel is because it's cheaper
well unfortunately you know the market
in steel isn't isn't a particularly fair
one
anyway internationally because as you
may know the
the chinese for example they have uh
massively uh subsidized their own steel
production in order to make that
cheap uh to be bought by by foreign
countries and
undercutting that domestic production
and that's been one of the challenges
over the last few years so you know i
think it's perfectly reasonable
and desirable uh of our work government
to say that we will have a buy
british uh guarantee it's uk taxpayers
uh money uh going on these big important
infrastructure projects and so i think
people would expect that
uh you know there would be preferential
treatment
for uk manufacturing to to benefit from
those contracts and as i say it's a i
think if this pandemic has taught us
anything that we need to have a lot more
resilience
in our own supply chains in our own
ability to produce things uh on our own
shores we do have world-leading
steel production um and it supports many
important jobs around
around the country and and we we should
have that long-term benefit
of of these government contracts
um i wonder what we have you um the
prime minister speaking to conservative
mps last
night suggested that our success in
terms of
vaccination was down to capitalism and
greed what did you make of that well
it's just
not my perception at all and i
think the mask has slipped really from
the prime minister there
i think what i take from our success
with the
vaccine production is that when
the government worked closely with
business
with research and development then we
can
really be world leading it's not a case
of just leave it to the market
at all it was government money working
with world leading science
and research that that funded the
research
for the oxford astrazeneca vaccine in
the first place
it was then government contracts that
then secured the production
of those vaccines and it was that
partnership approach
where the government takes the risk uh
with with the initial
uh contract and with the initial uh
research
and and then business doing what it does
best which is
being able to to produce and and
distribute
the vaccine once it's made so i have a
very very different
view about what has led to that
lisa powell great to have you on the
program this morning thanks for being
with us
thank you now
a large shipping container has blocked
egypt's suez canal
causing a traffic jam of ships around 15
of them are said to be stuck behind the
400 meter long ship with several tug
boats being deployed
to help move the vessel uh let's speak
to our middle east correspondent at
mark stone morning mark i mean the
pictures of this are
are quite remarkable do we understand
exactly what happened here it looks like
the poorest three-point turn i've ever
seen
uh well uh evergreen which is the
shipping company that runs
uh the ever given which is the ship in
question uh
is saying this morning that it was wind
uh they say that
wind pushed the vessel off course and
then carried it
and pushed it to its side as you can see
where it is placed now literally
blocking
the canal now that may seem far-fetched
i'm not a shipping expert
but certainly these ships are very very
large they're very very tall this was a
container ship
perhaps a very strong gust of wind could
begin to move it one way there is talk
of a
of a power failure on board as well so
the combination of those two perhaps
that was what caused this but certainly
a massive headache
not only for the captain of the vessel
but also for the management
of the suez canal upwards of 40 to 50
ships a day
travel through this one of the world's
arteries one of the most busy shipping
lanes in the world
clearly today and maybe for many days
there will be no
ships passing through it which will
increase the amount of time that ships
uh
need to take to travel this route by
about 15 days because they'll need to go
right round um
at the south at the bottom of the
african continent it's pretty windy here
too in jerusalem today
so yeah a big headache for people uh for
the the management of
of the suez canal at the moment it's a
spectacle but it could become a big
problem over the coming days
uh well let's take advantage of the wind
and keep looking at you're here for
another couple of minutes whilst you
tell us exactly what is going on in
terms of
israeli elections i mean they'd love an
election in israel don't they
yeah they do and and you know even
though this is the fourth election
yesterday was the fourth election in two
years the turnout was still
still pretty high they do love an
election most of us are getting pretty
fed up with it
but they did have another one yesterday
because of disagreements within
benjamin netanyahu's coalition so the
government collapsed at christmas
another election now and again the
result is looking like deadlock
benjamin netanyahu's netanyahu is
looking like he might be able to form
another coalition this is a man who has
led israel for upwards of 20 years
maybe he'll get another coalition 59
seats i think is what it's looking like
at the moment with
the coalition but perhaps he can get
that 61 target
we'll see but there'll be days of
coalition building mark
many thanks indeed uh still to come on
the program this morning health leaders
are warning the nhs that it will lose
thousands of staff if that is its
workers
aren't given mental health support after
the pandemic we'll be discussing that
next
[Music]
about half a mile from the turkish coast
and evidence that is the
boat seriously overcrowded this is one
of the
most severe viruses in the world
i'm alex crawford and i'm sky's special
correspondent based in
istanbul
a lot of action going on
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in the news
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
her arms look at her arms i can put my
entire
hand round
[Music]
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
once it takes out it's very very
difficult for these
firefighters to get a grip of it and get
on top of it and put it out
the world's largest falls now down to a
trickle in places
i can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge lake
getting up close and personal with a
rhino
this is what makes the job so
fantastic
[Music]
for the early risers
for the knowledge seekers
for the straight talkers the curious and
the ones who want to be entertained
backstage sky news's entertaining
podcast
[Applause]
sky news podcasts listen and subscribe
for free did you know that if we all
work together we can really make a
difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah
we should really do that today cloud and
some patchy rain or showers will spread
southeastwards across
england and wales and this will become
dry and sunny from the north as it does
but
southern coastal counties of england
will probably remain cloudy all day
meanwhile ireland northern ireland and
scotland will be sunny too but with
blustery and at times heavy showers
with the risk of some wintry outbreaks
over the high ground of scotland
so in regards to the air pollution
levels on a scale of 1 to 10 with 10
being
very high most places will continue to
see low levels of
1 to 3 however there may be some
moderate levels around coastal areas of
the northwest of scotland where winds
will be strong again
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
leaders are warning that the nhs will
lose thousands of
staff if that is its workers aren't
given mental health support after the
pandemic
the nhs confederation which represents
nhs organizations
warns that there's a significant number
of staff with anxiety and depression
a small minor in order to even have ptsd
we're joining us now to discuss this uh
professor rupert pierce himself a
consultant in intensive care medicine
at a london hospital professor always
good to see you thanks very much for
joining us on the show
once again and i suppose before we deal
with this in the macro let's let's let's
talk about your own
experiences i mean how how has it been
for you working
full tilt day after day after day and
some of the most challenging
circumstances of your career i imagine
well i i mean it it's been a very very
long year
it's been very tiring at times and on
top of
the hard work there have been periods of
intense worry when we haven't been sure
whether we
have enough hospital beds and other icu
beds for the patients coming into
hospital
and that we wouldn't be able to deliver
the quality of care that
we normally defend so highly in the nhs
so
uh a lot of hard work and a lot of worry
and anxiety throughout the last 12
months
i mean even before the pandemic were
there mental health resources
that you and your colleagues could could
call upon
working in the healthcare system outside
of a pandemic is a
is a stressful job i presume
there has been in the past some
recognition that healthcare workers have
a particular
exposure to mental health problems and
often present very late
for mental health support for various
different reasons and doctors are
particularly known to be bad for that
but during the pandemic we've had a very
different type of health experience
and we've been exposed to all sorts of
stresses and strains
and in particular this concept of moral
distress where
doctors nurses allied health
professionals have felt that they can't
deliver the standard of patient care
that they feel is the minimum and
that that becomes extremely distressing
and that's when you start to get
problems like post-traumatic stress
disorder
so what then in in your mind professor
needs to be done what services need to
be put in place
i mean it is it is clear that everyone
has had a tough old time over the past
12 months
but if we can't if if the government
isn't going to do more than a one
percent pay rise
for healthcare workers one imagines that
you know some mental health provision
might be quite useful
i think that there are a lot of people
who work in the nhs
who feel that they've been forgotten now
whether that
is or isn't the case they feel that way
and that certainly contributes to the
way that their mental health problems
play out
and and that's definitely the case with
a lot of nurses
who who when you listen to things like
like the debate about the pay rise
it just plays into that sense that
nobody quite realizes what they've been
through
and you know to some extent we don't
want other people to have had the
experience that we've had we don't want
the wider public to know
firsthand how hard it's been because we
want to shoot people to have that
experience as possible
but it leaves you in a situation where
the only people who truly understand
them hard it's been
our other nhs staff that they've worked
with and that can be very very difficult
so we need to look after each other as
nhs
staff but we also need access to the
kind of mental health support talking
therapies in particular
that can help staff to start to analyze
what they've been through
and think about how they handle that i
think some work is being done
the biggest worry i have is the time
staff need
to decompress following the experience
we've had
because we know that there are a whole
load of patients who haven't had the
usual health care that they need this
past year
there's patients who haven't had their
cancer treatments their cardiac
treatments
and so on and we don't want those
patients to be lost
either so we know that we've got to
swing into a whole new stream
of delivering usual healthcare at the
same time as remaining ready
for a further pandemic response because
we cannot
fail to be prepared even if it's
unlikely that we see
a big
i'm so sorry to have interrupted you
there professor but we are out of time
great to see you this morning and i hope
you managed to get a little bit of a
break sometime in the not too distant